the Supreme Court's decision dealt
another blow to president Mohamed
morsi's Freedom and Justice Party the
mostly secular opposition hopes the
ruling will weaken the Islamist
government's hold on power today the
Supreme Constitutional Court has issued
an historic ruling that both the
Legislature's upper house as well as the
constitutional panel were illegally
elected and now the president has to
dissolve the upper house of the high
limit sure the upper house known as the
Shura Council was made the country's
sone legislative power last year after
the Supreme Court dissolved the lower
house the council will remain in place
until a new Parliament is elected later
this year or in early 2014 the ruling
deepens the political instability in a
country yet to gain a foothold after the
Arab Spring experts believe it could
trigger a new power struggle between
Egypt's branches of government security
is being ramped up outside the court it
wants to prevent an escalation similar
to the one in December when Morsi
supporters tried to pressure the judges
into backing off a ruling that would
strip him of his immunity
you